[Music]
hey
i was a little slow on the uptake on
that [ __ ] thing there i was just kind
of like wait what am i doing oh yeah
okay
i'm really really tired yeah i do the
show
[Laughter]
i woke up at like three in the morning i
couldn't go back to sleep for like two
or three hours so it's a little pokey
was
sleeping on my legs and then she wanted
to make bread on my face
and then she was just like [ __ ] i was
just like i love you but
yeah i'm trying to sleep okay we saw a
movie last night it's called uh what was
it called the hunted
hunted hunted yeah it's kind of like a
take on little red riding hood
yeah yeah very loosely based on little
red riding hood
uh more like a about a serial killer
hunting down this woman
crazy ass serial killer yeah it's like a
survival horror essentially it's a
french movie
i think it was actually it's really
weird i couldn't find a hell of a lot of
information about this it's on shutter
they just added it
and from what i could determine this
movie is
a 2021 movie okay um
so it was shot in belgium i know that
much
all right but the weird thing about it
is french people well they speak french
don't they
bill yeah but the weird thing about it
though is that they never really say
where it is
okay so cause the main character like
the woman who's getting chased her
character's name is eve
and she's played by a french actress and
she's playing a french person
in the movie but she's obviously
either out of town or out of the country
because she's on a job she's like
supervising a construction site or you
know something
and um because they're building new
houses or you know something
and so i assumed she was out of the
country because she was staying in a
hotel and she didn't know anybody
and then when she goes to this bar it
seemed like most of the dudes that were
talking to her were
irish or american or something although
the weird thing is that like the main
serial killer guy like the main
antagonist i thought it was an american
because he's he's talking like an
american but that is actually a french
guy doing yeah
it's like a fake american accent yeah
it's a fake american and it's
it's spotty it's like it's like the
american accent you learn from watching
a bunch of old gangster movies or
something that's
that's what it is it's not from any kind
of region which that's
understandable yeah i mean i didn't
really trying to sound american have
been better if he just
tried to sound french although it didn't
occur to me that that was a french guy
i mean it didn't occur to me it was
foreign just from that accent
yeah yeah i guess i wasn't really
pandering it was like about three or
four accents just kind of mashed
together
you know yeah his sidekick was irish so
i'm pretty sure
it's harder too the whole thing didn't
matter it was an okay movie it was
pretty good
yeah it was pretty good it was a pretty
simple setup like i said um
eve is a french woman she is presumably
in this other unnamed country like i
said they shot it in belgium but i just
assumed it was everything is generic
it's wherever you want it to be
yeah it's just a just a generic place
it's forest and [ __ ] like that
so she's um so she's out of town um
they kind of imply that maybe she's
either having problems with work like
they keep [ __ ] with her or she's
having problems with her boyfriend and
she just doesn't want to deal with it
so she turns her damn phone off and says
you know what i'm gonna just gonna go to
some bar like close when i'm gonna go
get a drink or whatever
and so she goes there and she hooks up
with this one guy
you know they get drunk they dance he
seems okay he rescues her from some
other [ __ ]
jackal that's like you know trying to
[ __ ] harass her or whatever
but then it turns out that this guy is
a serial killer and also he has a
sidekick who the sidekick i feel like is
not
really into it as much this just seems
like some younger
i didn't i got the impression too that
maybe the sidekick was like
maybe had it was like a little mentally
challenged yeah you know what i'm saying
like he was kind of childlike
yeah so i kind of feel like the main
serial killer just likes having
a sidekick to help him out but he likes
to have somebody that he can manipulate
that's kind of the implication that i
got
in some ways it's like an italian flick
you just don't overthink it you just
watch it
yeah that's what you know what i mean
it's just
just like with an old italian giallo
flick if you try to analyze it too much
you'll go [ __ ] crazy because it
doesn't make any goddamn sense
it's just entertainment it's just art
and uh
yeah the sidekick i i didn't i didn't
really understand the characters
you know but i really wasn't expecting
too you know what i mean it wasn't
i wasn't trying to make this movie make
sense i was just watching it
well and as i said even though it's very
loosely based on
little red riding hood it did have a lot
of fairy tale or magical realist
type of yeah um aspects because
they kind of give you this at the
beginning there's like a there's like a
prologue a little bit with like this
older lady and a boy and they're sitting
by the fire and she's like
telling him like this fairy tale yeah
the whole thing is the tail
yeah so so and like i said some [ __ ]
happens in it that wouldn't happen in
real life
because basically what the gist of the
story is
is that the forest protects the innocent
so at many times during the period where
she's trying to get away from these two
jack wagons
the um animals in the forest like help
her out
you know what i'm saying like not in a
really you know like
for for one like a boar runs into the
road and makes the car crash so she can
get out of the trunk
um you know one of the dudes is trying
to kill her and like a a raven comes
down and like
starts [ __ ] with his face and stuff
so he can't get her so it's almost kind
of like the forest creatures
not in a you know oh it's snow white and
it's all like birds around their head or
anything but at certain
yeah at certain points it seems like
it's still realistic though
right but that's kind of um and
i guess if they hadn't established at
the beginning what the fairy tale was
that the forest protects the innocent
and so you know it's so it's the the
animals coming to her aid when she needs
it
they don't always because she gets
[ __ ] up and stuff but um
i yeah this was like a pretty decent uh
this is a pretty decent film it's really
weird i'm not really sure where it came
from it just kind of popped up suddenly
and i was just kind of like
it got like decent reviews on shutter i
think it's got four skulls on there or
something like that it wasn't bad
which um yeah it's it's very simple it's
not
um you know it's just basically a
survival horror it's a woman
running through the woods trying to get
away from killers
i actually could have done without the
snow white
and excuse me the red red riding hood
fairy tale angle i i don't think it
actually needed that
it probably didn't but i kind of liked
it i would have just i kind of liked
that though maybe got rid of the it had
a little
prologue i think i would have gotten way
got you know
gotten rid of that not worried so much
about the little red
or the little red riding hood motif yeah
she's wearing a red jacket but that
so what and then yeah the animals did
[ __ ] [ __ ] happened
it was been weirder not to know why
certain things happened
so it'd been like a giallo movie yeah
why did that happen
i don't know it's just it's just i i
think it i think it would have been
better if you asked me
i think knowing that it was kind of like
a take on a fairy tale
might have undermined it a little bit i
think i would have been more it would
have been you'd be more into it if you
didn't if i didn't know what it was you
didn't know what it was
yeah and it just and you know and if
maybe they had just allowed me to guess
that on my own
you know it's kind of like it added a
layer of cheese to it and undermined it
that's just what it gave me a little bit
of a company of wolves vibe too
but you know that was neil jordan right
that's the director's that's the
director's choice and
evidently you said it got good reviews
people liked that angle
so it's going to be a matter of taste i
really i think i could have done without
any reference to a little red rider hood
or any kind of legends or
fairy tales and just ran the damn movie
and just
let you make sense out of it i mean it
did have really i thought it had really
good tension particularly like in the
beginning where
she first gets um because like i said
she gets picked up by this guy and she
willingly like goes with a guy because
he seems nice and like they're dancing
it's like yeah let's
i'll go have some fun or whatever and
then it uh slowly takes a horrible
horrible turn
and it's interesting because you never
really know
where it's going like i know it seems
like she gets away but then they find
her again and like you know she ends up
she goes to this gas station and you
think it's going to be all right you're
not really sure where
it's going with it but then the dudes
like just keep stalking her and stalking
her
and i like too that they didn't really
they showed like the two guys i kind of
got a a vibe that they were like
lake and ing kind of because he took a
movie camera everywhere
and sometimes when he was like camping
out in the woods like waiting for her
looking for
he would like watch the movies so they
didn't show a lot of the stuff that
he did to the women that he kidnapped
because obviously he'd done this a bunch
of times
before because she gets like in the
trunk and there's some other chick cell
phone in there in purse and stuff
but um they just show like bits of it
on his video tapes they tell me to put a
wig on the spot
put a wig on spock
don't take away spock's dignity like
that
beezness says he sent me a flashlight
did i get it yet
[Laughter]
anyway you'll
[Laughter]
it was just uh i think the best part of
the movie was the serial killer that
that character was the best part of the
movie there was some really weird scenes
between him and his little [ __ ]
sidekicks and [ __ ] about do you love me
and weird [ __ ] like that it was just
i liked that dude's character he was he
seemed like an
unhinged weird crazy person there dudes
like
he had good acting too he's good acting
yeah i thought i mean accent was a
little
a little all over the place but it's all
right it didn't and i didn't
i didn't really notice it i mean i
didn't even think because i
now i did kind of be like no where is
this supposed to be at
yeah i'm trying to because she was
french but then she wasn't from around
there
yeah but then like some people were
talking and sounded like americans and
some people talking sounded like irish
people and then
it was in a fairy tale forest yeah but
like i said because they established at
the beginning because even the um
the credits were kind of like an
animated like a fair even when like the
old woman was telling the fairy tale
she wasn't an old woman she was you know
older uh you know an older woman was
telling the fairy tale they almost had
it animated kind of like uh
kind of like in bram stoker's dracula
with all the silhouette type
stuff but it was animation um but yeah
it's decent it's on shutter it's a
shutter original i guess
um so it's one of their new ones that
they just added
somebody asked me i can't remember who
it was
to review the dark and the wicked
and i just noticed today that shutter is
going to be adding that
soon because i'm not sure when but when
i was looking on there today because
i was watching like another video and
they said that they'd seen the dark and
the wicked
and it they'd seen it on shutter and i'm
like what is that on shutter i didn't
see that on there
and i check it like pretty much every
day or every other day
but i looked down there now the trailer
is on there and it says coming soon on
it so presumably i don't know
if it's next week or the week after so i
will so whoever it was that requested
that i do that movie i will get around
to doing that because shutter is going
to add it so
yeah i don't have to pay for it um you
know other than what i pay for
shutter um but yeah so uh
yeah this this was decent like i said if
you like
i know that there's kind of a whole i
don't even know if it's big enough to be
a sub genre but there is kind of a sub
genre of horror movies that are based on
fairy tales this one isn't real fairy
taley like i said
it's basically survival horror with like
a little bit of magical realism fairy
tale-y type of
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah stuff's like
sprinkled on top the fairy tale
element was just added in the first few
minutes of the damn movie it
you could have take you could have
edited and just the stuff with the
animals yeah but you wouldn't have
noticed had you edited it out
the stuff that happened with the animals
you would come up with another
explanation for it
yeah it didn't it wasn't obvious that it
was fairy tale
right if it wasn't for that intro
captain bleirdo says tom a real man uses
grits as lube for his fleshlight
it's the texture it's a texture yeah it
gives you a little bit of that something
something
i [ __ ] are sick
[ __ ] are sick i still i wrote down
over here from the from the stream on
saturday that somebody said something
about grits cookies and i was like i
wonder if there's a recipe for those
i don't think there's such a thing is
there oh come on there's gotta be
i mean you would make cookies out of
persimmons that's what i'm saying you
can make you could probably make cookies
corn cookies well that sounds cool that
sounds good
enough sugar and anything it's good but
well exactly i mean you can cookie
pretty much like you can cookie lots of
things
[ __ ] are crazy man but i said i meant
to look it up and i forgot somebody
really needs to look if there's a recipe
for [ __ ] grits cookies
grits are like ambrosia man it's like
food
nectar of the gods how do you insult
them
they only come into season once every 10
years
yeah like a locust you know what i was
just going to say that exact same thing
like a cicada they only come out over a
decade because that's 17 years isn't it
the locust life cycle i think it's 17
years louie says we should watch the
silencing
on amazon prime which is also a good
movie i will write that down
also i'll tell you something though when
i was a kid
you guys are [ __ ] going to think i'm
crazy but no
not you when i was a kid visiting
mississippi and stuff
oops sorry damn what happened was that
goblin because
i picked my thing up off the off the
thing and it
uh stuck there were more bugs in the
south remember there were a lot more
bugs in the south
i used to see those big old black and
yellow [ __ ] locusts
yeah everywhere huge grasshoppers
lots of cicadas
um everybody had a damn bug light on
their back porch it would sit there and
[ __ ] zap and all
that in fact all the frogs had come out
and eat all the damn
bugs that had been zapped and you just
don't see that anymore that was 70s i
don't know if it was
insecticides or just maybe uh
maybe has something to do with crop
yields aren't quite the same what they
were maybe they're not in this area
anymore and
because that those locusts had something
to do
with the with farming of the time yeah
so maybe they just maybe they just used
to uh
because farming wasn't as advanced for
some reason it just bred a lot more bugs
i don't know
i remember i just oh like i said i
remember my grandmother
just like she would have to go in her
garden and just like pick those things
off her plants because they'll eat all
your damn plants
you know what i mean yeah like locusts
because that's what maybe it's because
people had all those tomato gardens in
the backyard
yeah and okra growing okra all
throughout the south people
had their own backyard farms and maybe
maybe that just
bred a lot of damn bugs yeah and it's
not as good
you know the environment isn't as lush
as it used to be because there aren't as
many farms
yeah maybe it could be that because it
did seem like i mean she had a lot of
she didn't have like a big farm or
anything but she did have some tomato
plants and then she had like a whole
bunch of plants like in the front
yeah um a whole bunch of different
another thing i remember
was um just loads and loads of them damn
lizards i mean we still got a lot of
lizards
yeah there's garbage everywhere i
remember used to walk up
beside houses in mississippi for the
summer just back when i was six or seven
and the entire wall just filled with
[ __ ] lizards with like 200 of them
on on a single wall that's a little
lizard party and then they'd [ __ ] run
off like a whole flock of birds
yeah you don't see that anymore it's
weird
maybe well the population wasn't as
dense back then
there weren't as many people in the
south maybe they've spread out
yeah they might have spread out and you
know it's probably like a combination of
a lot of things maybe like more people
live there
like more people have cats that eat them
it's like you know what i mean it's kind
of like
so you know what i mean the the used to
be maybe all the bugs and the lizards
that group up on smaller neighborhoods
back then
yeah because neighborhoods weren't this
big that's yeah so just attract all of
them now they're spread out
yeah it's like these bear people think
the bear disappeared no they're all in
this [ __ ] neighborhoods
yeah i see them cruising through
people's yards every now and then around
like to do yeah what's up and this used
to be
on the edge of [ __ ] the town you know
i mean it used to
be almost be forest not anymore that's
moved out another 10
10 miles now yeah so i guess that's
where all the bear are now they're not
as common
yeah they probably just keep moving away
because they're like god damn it yeah
they don't want to stay at the edge
like we love your garbage cans and
everything but come on they're just
they're just staying at the edge but now
where we are you're not even allowed to
have regular garbage cans anymore
the the county gave everybody seminole
county gave everybody bear safe
ones that have that latch and stuff like
that to keep the bears from getting in
there
so yeah cause they don't wanna have to
shoot them so it's like we don't want
them hanging out in neighborhoods going
through everybody's garbage
so yeah they'll find you if you have
like a regular one but that that's
seminole county i don't know about it
the other counties in florida but
just because a lot of this i mean this
county is pretty small
and uh a lot of this county is still a
little bit rural
yeah badgers in there talking about
grits his [ __ ] line yes [ __ ] up in
england
you know what grit tastes like have you
even had grits dude
go get you a bag of grass order a bag of
instant [ __ ] quick grits or something
quaker put some cheddar cheese in there
and hard-boiled eggs and some sausage
there's some bacon
some bacon bacon yeah but a lot of
butter salt and pepper
yeah yeah come back and tell me and
diced up
diced up peppers maybe like green red
peppers or green peppers or something i
mean when i was growing up i would just
eat them
with a with salt pepper and a big thumb
of butter in there that's like you can
eat them like that but they're good with
a bunch of other stuff good
diced up ham yeah cheese
whole hard-boiled eggs in there yeah
taking a spoon and just
getting some egg and hard-boiled egg and
then get some grits with it
cheesy grits yeah man i got it i got it
in the cookbook
quaker the quaker uh instant grits which
is the most popular brand in the us
at least they even have a red-eye gravy
and ham
flavor yeah that you can buy i've never
had that flavor
and then order go online order some tony
sachery's frickin
um cajun seasoning put some of that in
the grits
with cheese and everything else you
never take an ingredient away from grits
just pile on top
[Laughter]
once you get all that done throw some
ramen in there with it
and then a piece of chocolate cake
that's a chocolate cake
put a rabbit in it i'll put all these
cheese in it yeah
[Laughter]
well if you're gonna get diabetes you
might as well go all in you know what
i'm saying
yeah not fat as hell and [ __ ] in your
pajamas and [ __ ] walking around
three o'clock in the afternoon and
you're [ __ ] jammies
with a big thing of sweet tea yeah
standing out front drink like a gallon
yeah yeah you got a gallon of sweet tea
one
and then [ __ ] a two liter of [ __ ]
fago in the other rc cola
yeah you'd flip flaps and [ __ ]
all right okay so hanging from a tree
well yeah like you do tires and [ __ ]
everywhere yeah old fridges and [ __ ]
yeah fridge you gonna fix one day
oh my god that's [ __ ] terrible i know
man it's like
i grew up in daytona i know exactly what
you're talking about gonna fix that
fridge one day
that's still good i had to take the door
off of it so kids don't go in there
exactly
they have two refrigerators that's what
[Laughter]
all right so uh we'll be back tomorrow
talking about another movie probably
so i hope you guys have a good rest of
your day and uh we'll see you tomorrow